you love a posting cat pictures you're  obsessed with pictures of people and  their cats yeah I'd like to post them is  that right I have a very beautiful cat  and she deserves to have people look at  it right perfect  right so I found this thing I don't know  if you guys know what that's called cat  bearding cat bearding I have not heard  of cat pictures you might show it these  are these are other people cat bearding  right those are good but my cat isn't  down with that stuff right your cat  doesn't want to play that game not into  it so I tried really hard to get her to  cooperate and let's see what your  attempts were these are fail that's out  okay  that's not so good and then is there one  of you just being clawed at it looks  like I'm strangling her cuz I'm like  pushing for a stop but I had to treat up  here he's like right right yeah just  leave your catalog dad doesn't need that  you